thank you yes sir yes we are here with
Alex careforth Financial Analyst at
Edward Jones and a good friend here in
St Louis Alex welcome to the show thank
you Christian you're also a trustee of
the U.S chess trust fund tell us a bit
about that and what's the mission of the
farm I mean for several decades the U.S
chess trust has been a
sponsor of Scholastic programs across
the country uh very excited to have the
opportunity to be added as a trustee and
continue to see the something that I'm
passionate about being able to be put
into action through the trust and most
recently we're involved in a new library
project where we're seeing different
types of boards and tournaments
happening in libraries across the
country so it's been a good Endeavor
really enjoy it that's definitely a cool
mission that you guys have at the trust
also you are a founder of the corporate
chess League I know that we have the
Collegiate chess League you guys have
the corporate foreign tell us a bit
about that and the vision behind that I
mean the the whole idea of the St Louis
corporate chess League was to find a way
where different companies could come and
have cross-industry ideas sharing have
an opportunity to network build
friendships across something that we all
really enjoy which was playing chess and
so when I had talked with the team here
at the St Louis chess club of course
they go well above and beyond to make
this this little idea an amazing reality
I think we have seven teams now as you
can see on the dates there The Fall
season has just kicked off I will say
there seems to be a correlation
Christian between Financial folks and
chess Edward Jones has won six of the
last seven seasons and so I'm pretty
proud about that and we need some some
new talents too easy to come in someone
come and take this Champion you're the
captain of Edward Jones right and
Captain yeah so it's been uh on this uh
this semester captain
hey we're we're going to compete again
we always have our Arch Rivals over at
Enterprise who are ready to to jump on
and uh and take it to us but um I think
the team's going to do pretty well again
hopefully get to the the final four and
we also have this uh cool thing the
strategy across the board you're
involved with that as well what's the
plan for uh this year the the vision of
strategy across the board is the St
Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame and the amazing things that
we're doing throughout the entire
Metropolitan St Louis area some 80 000
students throughout Metro St Louis are
being taught mentored given
opportunities to enjoy this game and
seeing it translate to excelling in the
classrooms different studies that we've
done that show a correlation there and
so a lot of the proceeds of this Gala
will help go and continue to support the
Scholastic program and then also the
World Chess Hall of Fame so having the
different composers series music series
of course the amazing art exhibitions
that go on throughout the year is also
being supported through the gala and
it's just a lot of fun to be able to
plan and be a part of chess boards that
you've never seen before very exotic
ways that you can actually have an
opportunity to bid on those and some
amazing keynote speakers and and
different chess folks that you would
you'd love to meet so come to the gala
December 3rd it's awesome no absolutely
it's a lot of fun we usually go there I
think the after party we have some
videos on YouTube with Yasser dancing
Alejandro dancing and things of that
nature it's a lot of fun guys any
questions for uh Alex absolutely first
of all uh thank you Alex for all you've
done and congratulations to being a
chess trustee U.S chess trust I think
when I think of the U.S chest trust I
think of the this um this separate body
from the USCF that supports the chess
and schools program that's Dwayne Barber
and all of these national
championships and uh you guys just
impact So Many Lives I mean it's
extraordinary talk about the history and
how it is how the U.S chess trust has
evolved because what you've been doing
it wasn't around or maybe it was it just
wasn't it was kind of dormant but it
wasn't around in my age
I mean so another aspect that I can see
I mean is is exhibited by the players
that you see on the screen today many of
which have been recipients of the
Samford Fellowship exactly and receiving
funding to continue their their chess
careers and it had a lot of relationship
historically with the United States
Chess Federation now has has grown into
its own entity but those are some of the
things that will be the legacy of the
United States Chess trust as well as
being the voting members of who gets
into the Chess Hall of Fame boats in the
United States and the World Chess Hall
of Fame so a lot of Rich history and and
folks that I feel like I get the
opportunity to work with who I've looked
up to or maybe you haven't heard of but
have had massive influences on United
States Chess overall well again the
Samford because you mentioned a big
shout out to Al Lawrence the managing
director of the U.S Chester and
everything that he does but the Sanford
Fellowship these are huge grants that
allow the players to really hone their
game and I think in this event
the Samford has sponsored over the
history 11 of the 14 players in the open
wow and Alice Lee for example today is a
Samford fellow I'd talk about the
leadership that's going on there with
the Sanford fellow
Grant Awards sure well it's it's really
inspiring that chess can reach so many
different people and the desire for
someone to want to to give a donation in
perpetuity right to continue to see the
opportunity for for chess careers
launched has has like you said produced
numerous Champions some of our
up-and-coming prodigies in the United
States and and allowing them to continue
to travel to different tournaments be
able to receive the coaching and
mentoring that that is necessary to
compete at a high level and so that that
type of donation and and vision For
Those Behind the Samford is is really
special for the United States
thank you so much again Alex for
everything you do that the chest stress
does and again a very big shout out to
Al Lawrence uh everybody's favorite uh
chess supporter thank you thank you
thank you for being on the show again uh